it's so funny i just said this the other
day about um
vince gilligan one of the things i love
is that
he like listen like he is who he is it's
not like this this guy goes
in with details you know like he's so
like he's just like wildly smart and
talented
but he also in this takes a certain a
lot
you know certain amount of confidence
that a lot of people or networks don't
have he's he's like i'm gonna let the
show go where it goes
you know like sometimes you have to uh
and and i think that's so
key to making good
television or movies um and i feel like
i got to be a part of that and see it it
was really exciting like i know some of
the things they had planned that we told
we ended up not doing and now that you
look back at it you know
if this the the choices they made were
far better
than the than what we thought you know
like maybe they thought they were going
to do
and um i just i loved watching
their process i'm not a writer and so i
i loved watching that
and i have to say the this group of
actors the first time
we um i've i felt like oh my god i could
live with them forever
was um the intervention scene the
talking pillow
and it just i
i will never forget this day oh my god
and it just
it was like it was contagious and it
just worked so well
it was as if we had been working
together for years and rehearsed to this
there was just such a rhythm
that we had and you and it was so
special and you felt the crew
feel it and they everyone was just so
excited about i think that was when we
were really aware of like
what this cast was together and it was
it's still to this day
one of the best scenes i've ever shot
in my life i i texted vince and said i
want to make t-shirts that say
intervention and whatever year it was i
really don't know what year it was
um because i said it was just like such
a swell
of enthusiasm and pride and
it was um honestly i can remember
shooting that scene like i'm watching a
movie i remember the conversations i had
with dean
i like all of it i i remember asking for
another take and i was pretty young in
my career and so i felt like i shouldn't
do that and dean was like
ask for another one and i did and that
was like the one that i and i
did everything i wanted to do in those
moments
um and it was great and like dean and i
found some humor in there and
it was you know just it's to this day
like one of the best scenes i'm sure
i'll say that if you ask me 20 years
from now i'll bring up that scene